[Music]
welcome back Hannity Hillary Clinton
refuses to accept the fact that she lost
the election of President Trump in an
interview with NPR Clinton said that she
won't rule out contesting the election
and the election results if there's
actual proof of so-called Russia
election interference now this is the
exact opposite of what Clinton tweeted
about Donald Trump last October remember
she tweeted this quote Donald Trump
refused to say that he'd respect the
results of the election that's a direct
threat to our democracy here now former
Obama economic adviser Austin Goolsbee
all right so the media and all the
conspiracy theorists on these other
cable channels and the New York Times
Washington Post they've been telling us
Russia Russia Russia you follow the news
as closely as anybody I know Austin can
you name one piece of evidence that we
have of Trump Russia collusion in the
election
well you backed away there now it's only
Donald Trump himself in a couple of
months ago you told me there was no
evidence of the campaign's collusion
okay I'll help you out can you name me
specific evidence that has been cited of
Trump campaign and Russia collusion in
the election or the DNC emails of John
Podesta emails do you have any evidence
of it at all that you can say to
everybody suggestive evidence certainly
there suggested give me a pic give me a
little need on a ball okay give me
subject the the fact that they sent an
email to Don jr. saying we have dirt on
Hillary Clinton and he says I love it
let's have a meeting is that different
evidence all right
that's that is evidence of a collusion
that's evidence of collusion here's the
question I have when a DNC paid staffer
met with the Ukrainian embassy with the
Ukrainian ambassador at the Embassy and
then reported back to the DNC and
reported back to Hillary Clinton's
campaign is that worse than what you're
saying is the little tiny meat on the
bone what you're giving me is maybe a
little morsel of I don't mean I don't I
don't know on on the
crane I haven't done in the oh you know
about the Ukraine hold on I haven't seen
the argument that the Ukraine was trying
to criminally well excuse me they were
they actually leaked information to try
and her gonna Trump they're in the
election and a DNC pagezephyr I'll
connect with Ukrainian John we're old
friends and I'm a concede your point it
is in my opinion not Hillary Clinton's
place to declare that she considers the
election suspect or not she was the
candidate that's for the American people
and the usually what's the crime is
let's say let's say there's no crime you
and I are running against each other for
president let's make everybody laugh
first okay okay now something that'll
never happen and plus I'd win I'm the
good-looking one in that yeah yeah no I
well if you consider losing lucky that's
fine I'm okay with that
all right but we're running against each
other for president and all of a sudden
somebody tells me I got information that
you need to know about Austan Goolsbee
that is going to impact this election
and the American people need to know is
there any crime if I meet with them and
try and find out what they had there
could be but let me say this what would
the project each other and they come to
tell me that I'm gonna tell them to go
sit and spin and if they're the Russians
I'm gonna call the FBI you're gonna
you're gonna call the FBI and you're not
gonna listen if there's not you admit
there's no nation's call me up there's
no anybody and you know who I'm gonna
cite as my source is Alan Dershowitz
liberal enough for you yes he is me
right there with you he's kind of close
liberal with you yeah that's pretty look
he agrees with me look he may agree with
you but she on that we haven't gotten
the report from Muller and the FBI I
hope that there is no crime that if
there is anything untoward that it was
some marginal person in the campaign and
that person's held to account and it has
nothing to do with the president because
if it goes higher then we will be in a
constitutional crisis and I don't
that to happen it we don't have a
constitutional crisis and after
everybody in the country for a year even
Comey and clapper and Brennan and
everybody in the intelligence community
said no there's no evidence but there's
smoke after year or smoke give me some
meat on the bone or it's got to go away
this is a distraction and an attempt to
delegitimize a duly elected president
and you should be asking your side -
knock it off because it's hurting the
country well I have I have and as I say
I don't think that Hillary Clinton
should be getting up and saying she
doesn't all right I got all she might
not certify so I kind of half I'd win if
it's you versus me it's over I'm gonna
win cuz you supported Obama's failed
economic agenda 13 million food stamps 8
million more impoverished labor
participation rate under you look
through the president is yeah Donald
Trump thank God all right well we come